[Music]
Adam was always with a microphone and
guitar so he would go all day long yeah
I try to make uh drew a jewel ER yeah he
and he did all the time too and and
sometimes we'd laugh too hard and then
we'd get the giggles and then it would
be all over and we couldn't go on with
the scene because who gets a giggle who
can tell Drew to stop playing but it's
beautiful to see everybody having a nice
time and one angry guy like right after
20 minutes of like I need to shoot
I think the important thing is the
experience and to have a wonderful
experience
that's what we had you know and we had
so much fun making this movie You're The
Wedding Singer
chemistry seems to rule out everything
else and on a chemical level alone I
think Adam Sandler is beautiful and I've
always said that I think the most
attractive human quality a human being
can attain is humor and intellect and he
has a book you know so how can that not
be attractive so he is sexy I hope yes
very sexy oh my God all my girlfriends
they never come to visit me at work
they're all here they're like
it's so cool you know Adam's charm comes
through and his character Robbie Hart
Who falls in love with Drew's Julia a
new waitress at the reception hall where
he works
I did my best I don't I it's it's not
the best thing to do kiss me but I tried
I tried my hardest
hey friends so he made
through the matters I'd be in love with
this man he is charming and funny and
smart and witty and clever and so
handsome and I just love him and I I
love knowing him
grows old with you a few fun facts about
the box office hit the late Carrie
Fisher was actually an uncredited script
doctor for the film apparently the role
of Julia's fiancee Glenn gulia was
written with Jim Carrey in mind and
Betty White was considered for the role
of Rosie
[Music]
Adam and Drew reunited in two more films
50 First Dates and Blended we've been
looking for something to do for a while
but we wanted to find the right thing
with a story that we loved and exactly
you know otherwise we could have done
the Wedding Singer too okay we never
even talked about that let's do it now
okay
hey this is our fifth 15th movie uh yeah
Drew's been good and this will be the
first 15 times a charm that's right and
while there's still no word on The
Wedding Singer 2 Drew's manifesting a
sequel I feel like Adam and I are sort
of due for maybe another movie so if we
did a Wedding Singer too we better bring
it because I think you can't let that
down
[Music]
foreign